Bonjour à tous ! Moi c'est Sylvain Lefebvre.
Biologiste de formation, photographe, cinéaste,
et guide naturaliste de profession, je suis
notamment le réalisateur du film "Jardin sauvage"
et l'auteur du livre "Safari au jardin".
Ma passiondans la vie : observer les animaux. Les plus grands
comme les plus petits. Et l'endroit où je passele
plus de temps pour ça, c'est mon jardin.
Après un film, un livre, je vous présente donc une
web-série tournée 100 % à domicile avec
un double objectif :
1) vous raconter monexpérience du réensauvegement
de notre jardin familial et
2) vous présenter quelquesespèces remarquables de la faune sauvage
quel'on peut trouver chez soi.
Prêts pour des jardins qui chantent et qui enchantent ?
Allez c'est parti !
Notre jardin est un terrain de 1200 m² où
la moitié de la surface est dédiée à labiodiversité.
Pour les oiseaux et les insectes,
c'est un petit coin de paradis tout trouvé.
Il se situe à mi-chemin, entre la ville et
la campagne, dans la commune d'Acigné prèsde Rennes.
Un petit lopin de terre breton qui
résiste donc encore et toujours à l'envahisseurbéton.
Pour bien comprendre de quoi on parle,
rappelons juste une petite définition : celledu mot biodiversité !
Ce terme désigne à la
fois l'ensemble des organismes vivants surTerre,
les milieux dans lesquels ils vivent et
la diversité des interactions qui existententre eux.
Cela concerne donc aussi bien les
bactéries que les champignons, la flore quela faune.
Et rien que pour les animaux, dans un jardin où la nature
va garder une place importante,
on peut sans difficulté
accueillir des dizaines d'espèces différentes.
Pour accueillir la biodiversité chez soi, une
seule règle d'or : bio et diversité !
En d'autres termes, il s'agit de quitter le plus possible les
étendues de gazon stériles, qu'il faut voir comme un
véritable désert biologique. À la place sur tout
ou partie de votre jardin, l'idée de proposer à la
faune une série de micro-habitats où ils pourront
se nourrir, se cacher, se reproduire, ou même hiberner.
Arbres et arbustes, prairies fleuries,
végétation spontanée, mare, haie de boismort,
murets de pierres sèches, gîtes à abeilles,
nichoirs... Plus vous diversifiez la flore
et les aménagements, plus vous aurez
d'espèces animales à recenser chez vous !
Le plus important : semer, planter et planter encore.
Bien sûr, il y aura quelques réflexes à adopter.
Premièrement ne plus utiliser depesticides.
C'est d'ailleurs interdit par la loi depuis 2019.
Ensuite ne plus tailler ses haies auprintemps
Pour éviter de déranger les oiseaux qui pourraient y nicher.
Et enfin y aller mollosur la tondeuse, dès que les beaux jours reviennent.
Évidemment, le succès de votre jardin vivant
et de la biodiversité qui lui sera associée
sera fonction de votre environnement proche.
Vous n'aurez pas les mêmes résultats dans
un jardin au centre ville qu'en pleine
campagne. Mais n'oublions pas pour autant
que la nature sait faire preuve de
résilience et qu'elle s'invite partout
dès qu'on lui laisse de la place, souvent
même avec des espèces protégées par la loi.
C'est le cas de l'inoffensive couleuvre
à collier. Ce serpent, comme tous les reptiles
et amphibiens de France, bénéficie en effet
d'un arrêté de protection mis à jour en 2021.
En quittant le modèle du jardin purement récréatif,
on peut donc proposer collectivement une somme de
petites réserves naturelles pour notre faune et
je vous garantis que ça marche !
En quelques années, ici dans notre jardin familial, nous avons vuapparaître de nouvelles espèces comme la libelluledéprimée,
le triton alpestre, ou le phasme gaulois.
Cesanimaux s'ajoutent à plus d'une centaine d'insectes
différents, plus de 30 espèces d'oiseaux, mais aussi
des escargots, des araignées, des grenouilles,
des rongeurs ou des espèces emblématiques comme le
hérisson d'Europe où l'écureuil roux.
Ce sera tout pour cette petite vidéo d'introduction.
Je vous donne donc rendez-vous pour une série
d'épisodes qui entreront un peu plus dans les
détails de la vie secrète de nos oiseaux, de nos
abeilles, de nos papillons, ou encore des habitants
de la mare. Alors je vous dis à bientôt et ciao !